صار في تهديد وجودي بمعنى
سابقا للمحاوله الاولى التي حاول
الشباب
المتشددين يعني محاصره هذا الشخص
وايزاؤه او قتله
بعد بالفشل نتيجه تدخل بعض الاطراف الاخرى
اللي موجوده داخل المهجى الشيخ
لكن مجيء
ابو القعقاع ومحاوله استثماره
بالتشدد ودائما المتشدد يحاول ان يوجد
عدوا لكي يشد العصبه
خاصه حول مجموعه يعني تحتاج الى شد العصب
التنظيمي الطائفي الديني وهذا غير خاص
بالمتدينين فقط انما كل فكر متشدد متطرف
كل المؤدب كل
الجيولوجيات بالضبط كل الايديولوجيات
يحتاج الى عدوك كي يشد العصب التنظيمي
ويشد ويزيد اللحمه اللحمه يعني بين اطراف
صار في خطر فاذا كان في خطر وجودي ولكن
اضطر البعض الى ان يحموك باجسادهم هذا في
البدايه في المره الاولى في المره الثانيه
كان في تحريض يومي
من قبل ابو القحاب بين صفوف المجموعه التي
تدين بالولاء له يعني من نفس التنظيم تبعه
يعني بس صاروا يحرسوك يعني بعض الاشخاص
صاروا يحرسوا
ولا يكفي نقسم الاحداث هنا بينك وبين
صديقك يعني
لا يشكل حمايه كافيه يعني
فكان في احساس بالخطر احساس بالخطر
جابه بهالطريقه ولكن عندما نتحدث عن هؤلاء
الاخرين جميعا من المعتقلين والسجناء هل
كان معظمهم يعرف التهم الموجهه لهم لانه
في بعضهم شارك في عمليات صحيح
اللي شارك بالعمليات عمليات مسلحه
واشتباكات مع السلطه تنظيم وعد فقط
يعني في اطراف ايضا اسلاميه متدينه موجوده
ما لها علاقه
صوفيه مسالمه جدا يعني كمان ولا تميل الى
العنف ابدا يعني بس حتى اللي مش نشارك
بافعال اجراميه او ارهابيه او كذا يوضع في
نفس السجن في نفس المهجه
داخل
نيابه عن المقلوب لكي يظهر ويقبض عليه